euh comment réagiriez-vous si vous étiez
euh tranquillement à une terrasse d'un
café que soudain à la table d'à côté
vous étiez certain de reconnaître Xavier
Dupont de Ligones euh l'homme le plus
recherché de France c'est ce qui est
arrivé à Romain puertelas euh ex-picier
il va tout nous raconter euh il a un
ancien ami de Xavier Dupont de ligonis
sera aussi avec nous dans un instant un
garçon qu'on qu'on aime beaucoup euh qui
est déjà venu nous voir il sera il va
s'installer là dans dans quelques
minutes c'est Bruno de stabenrat bien
sûr qu'on aime beaucoup et qui est un
des amis euh bien sûr de Xavier Dupont
de ligonè et apparemment Xavier du pond
liuness serait vivant c'est un truc de
fou sachez-le voilà ce qu'il va nous
raconter vous allez voir d'ailleurs
c'est l'objet d'un roman comment j'ai
retrouvé Xavier Dupont de Ligones va
nous en parler dans un instant et c'est
vrai que vous vous je sais que c'est
c'est l'affaire qui passionne le plus
les Français c'est un truc de fou oui
oui l'affaire Grégori l'affaire du pont
de ligonis c'est les deux grandes
affaires non résolues qui sont qui qui
suscite l'émotion de toute la France
vous allez voir c'est va avoir des
révélations très très fortes regardez
petit qui
récape en 2011 les Français découvrent
avec effroid la terrible affaire Xavier
Dupont de Ligones trois corps et même un
4è juste à l'instant ont été découverts
13 ans plus tard l'homme suspecté
d'avoir tué toute sa famille n'a
toujours pas été retrouvé malgré une
fausse piste en 2019 l'information de
cette soirée l'arrestation de Xavier du
pont de Ligones cette affaire non
élucidée l' perplexe de nombreux
français si certains pensent que Xavier
Dupont de Ligones est décédé d'autres
estiment qu'il est toujours en vie
romain pettrolas vient de sortir un
nouvel ouvrage dans lequel le romancier
revient sur cette affaire et déclare que
le meurtrier présumé ne s'est pas
suicidé alors Xavier Dupond de LionZ
serait toujours vivant un de ses amis et
un expcier qui a enquêté s'exprime dans
TPMP merci Romain Puertolas ex-picier
écrivain euh auteur de ce roman on va on
va on va vous dire des choses
incroyables ce soir comment j'ai
retrouvé Exavier du pont de ligonis nous
en parler dans un instant et un garçon
que j'adore vous aussi hein je vais vous
adorer c'est sûr déjà j'adore votre
livre donc déjà mais Bruno de stabenrade
qui est déjà venu nous voir plusieurs
fois écrivain et Bruno c'est vrai que
c'est toujours un bonheur de t'avoir je
le sais tu es un garçon que j'aime
beaucoup voilà Bruno déjà comment tu
avais tu nous avais déjà parlé mais
comment tu avais rencontré que avait du
pont de Ligones toi quand on avait 16
ans on était en terminale ensemble à
versaill ah c'est ça ouais et puis on
habitait dans la même rue on avait la
même moto et on aimait les Bach boys
Elvis et on on est devenu tu sais c'est
comme un coup de foudre d'amour quoi
véta vraiment pote ah bah oui oui et
puis pendant des années on s'est vu
régulièrement mes parents étersés ça il
estess aussi et puis voilà puis le et
puis jusqu'en 2008 crois que c'est la
dernière fois où je l'ai vu c'est
quelques années avant avant les crimes
quoi alors les crimes oui et on va 2011
exactement ça c'est 2011 donc est-ce que
juste avant qu'on ait les infos de de de
Romain et Lestienne aussi parce qu'il y
a des grosses infos ce soir qu'on a
appris notamment dans dans dans le livre
juste il était comment est-ce qu'il
c'était un garçon normal ou est-ce que
tu te disais c'est un mec qui peut faire
un truc de fou non il était aussi sympa
que toi ah ouais ça me fait peur ça
rép cétait non non c sinon il aurait pas
été mon ami pas vraiment mais gen ouais
tu c'est un mec normal enfin très sympa
très très avec beaucoup d'humour enfin
céit un vrai copain quoi tu sais c'est
difficile de alors c'est vrai qu'il y a
des on peut pas savoir la vie
mystérieuse tu sais le le le jardin
secret bien sûr quand tu parles avec les
flies qui te disent quand tu regardes
l'historique internet tu vois des des
des gens ou des des gens qui sont
accusés tu découvres des vérité Xavier
il y a forcément une part d'ombre que je
connaissais pas alors mais avec moi il
était la tu étaé génial quoi alors juste
il y a vraiment des trucs de fou on va
en parler parce que dans le livre
notamment on a appris même cette
histoire de trouple on va en parler dans
un instant avec Romain et c'est vrai que
même physiquement quand on voyait Xavier
Dupont de ligonè on se disait c'est
c'est notre conseiller financier quoi
c'est un mec voilà c'est c'est c'est il
était comment avec les filles avec tout
ça quand tu était avec lui je peux te
dire que le sexe c'était pas son truc
enfin dit que parce qu'on on on lu a
donné plein de maîtresses c'est pas vrai
Xavier c'est quelqu'un qui a était
fidèle à niè jusqu'au jour où il a
découvert qu'elle le trompait avec son
meilleur ami ça mais après voilà et puis
il a eu une mîtr qui s'appelait
Catherine à qui il a emprunté 50000 €
mais il comptait le rendre il a toujours
remboursé cette dette Xavier toujours
ouais c'était voilà alors on va et le
sexe c'était pas son truc quoi voilà
c'est c'est c'est quand euh vous vous le
reconnaîtriez phement ah oui ah oui bien
sûr parce qu' mon av il il a dû faire il
fait 1,80 là il est un peu tassé avec
les années mais le regard la voix parce
que en fait la seule chose qu'on connaît
de Xavier de vivant c'est sa voix c'est
le dernier message qu'il laisse à sa
sœur le soir où il va y avoir les crimes
où il dit on était auussoc on éit au
restaurant là je vais coucher les
enfants ils disent ça c'est horrible
parce qu'on sait que dans 3 4 He ils va
les tuer et c'est mais il y a pas de
vidéo donc donc les gens le voient
partout et nulle part c'est fou cette
histoire il fallutoir merci Romain aussi
d'être avec nous euh romain
euh vous êtes euh vous allez nous
raconter une scène du livre vous avez
l'impression de voir queavie du pont de
liones un café en Espagne c'est quoi
cette histoire alors non c'est pas un
café sur la terrasse de mon de de chezma
en fait je vis je vis dans le sud de
l'Espagne et en fait un matin sur la
terrasse de mon voisin je vois un homme
qui ressemble énormément à X pon ligonis
en pign noir blanc en train de regarder
la mer en train de boire un café et euh
c'est quelque chose que j'avais déjà dit
plusieurs fois à ma femme c'est-à-dire
ici c'est parfait en Espagne il est pas
connu du tout hein l'affaire n'est pas
connue du tout faut savoir que hors des
frontières françaises ce n'est pas du
tout connu hein et euh et donc d'un coup
je vois cette personne donc
effectivement mon voisin qui loue sa
maison sur
nbnb donc plausible je commence à
quinter un peu euh finalement non ça
donne rien c'est pas ça mais euh le
romancier qui est en moi voit tout de
suite en fait une histoire je me dis
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si vraiment
c'était arrivé et je pars sur cette idée
de roman le roman
commence c'est en même temps un roman et
une enquête et effectivement c'est un
roman oui avec une vraie enquête que
j'avais fait à partir des années 2011 et
j'ai repris en fait cette véritable
enquête avec de véritables éléments et
je les ai mélangé à ma connaissance de
la police au frontière et je les ai mis
des éléments incroyables alors déjà dans
votre livre relatez le comportement
intrigant d'un des meilleurs amis av du
pond ligon Michel Retif c'est un des
éléments qui vous intrigue le plus le 6
avril 2011 alors que Dupont de ligonè
s'emploie a caché les corps et qu'il a
désactivé son téléphone son ami parvint
à le joindre c'est le dernier coup de
fil qu'il a eu alors c'est quoi cette
histoire ça déjà c'est un truc de fou
bah le téléphone est éteint toute la
journée puis vous avez il active le
téléphone vers 21h45 je crois et il y a
une conversation de 25 minutes avec
cette personne là son son meilleur ami
et ensuite il a rééteint le téléphone
donc déjà première circonstance première
coïncidence vraiment énorme
et la deuxième c'est que quelques jours
plus tard du 13 au 15 on va avoir les
deux téléphones de ces personnes donc
Xavier et son amis qui vont borner dans
la même zone de rock brune sur Argence
c'est-à-dire qu'ils arrivent au même
endroit le 13 au même moment et il
repartent le 15 donc loness disparaît et
son ami rentre chez lui à ce moment-là
donc là on a vraiment des indice
concordant et grave de penser qu'il y a
eu quelque chose son c'est c'est c'est
qui Michel Retif pour lui son meilleur
ami mais c'est oui c'est c'est quoi
c'est son vraiment son c'est ah c'est
son oui c'est son meilleur ami c'est son
frère entre guillemets c'est vraiment ou
quelqu'un qui avec lui parce pourquoi
alors les enquêteurs c'est ça qui est
fou je vous le dis à 20h58 en direct
c'est que les enquêteurs ont interrogé
Michel Retif et il dit il dit juste non
en fait ça a duré quelques secondes et
ils ont très vite balayé la piste de son
meilleur ami alors que là vous donnez
deux éléments extrêmement troublant
c'est le dernier mec qui est au
téléphone pendant 25 minutes euh deux
ils étaient au même endroit euh au même
moment tous les deux donc et et on a
l'impression qu'ils ont balayé très vite
cette piste est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter ça oui alors c'est bon c'est
assez ouioui c'est assez intriganton il
faut savoir que quand il y a une
information judiciaire c'est juge
d'instruction qui qui donne des euh des
des ordres des pistes à suivre à la
police al le truc c'est que Michel Retif
a été interrogé comme simple témoin en
fait alors est-ce que c'est une
stratégie du juge instruction qui ne
veut pas la foler qui l'interroge ok il
ne dit rien et ensuite on a mis un
dispositif de surveillance de la BR de
Montpellier qui n'a rien donné
évidemment mais dans ce cas-là moi je
pense qu'il faut donc maintenant le
reprendre et le mettre sous mise en
examen témoins insisteré quelque chose
de beaucoup plus coercitif ils ont juste
demandé genre voilà bah les auditions de
témoins c'est ça reste il y a pas de
moyen de coercitif dans la police on
peut pas mettre la pression heinement et
je pensais je pense qu' alors il faut il
faudrait savoir faudrait parler avec le
juge d'instruction pour savoir pourquoi
il y a pas eu cette ce moyens coeritif
exercé sur cette personne parce qu'on
avait vraiment quelque chose alors je ne
dis pas qu'il est 100 % coupable je dis
qu'on a pas été jusqu'au bout pour
savoir tout c'est très Michel Retif ce
qui est fou aussi c'est qui mais fin
séjour euh là le le vendredi 2 mars 2019
euh donc là il a plus cancer oui oui
mais c'est et Emmanuel euh teneur c'est
de meilleurs est mort d'alcoolise VO
enfin il ils ont été détruits par cette
affaire hein bien sûr ouais